the weekend fire at the crazy horse two
may be out but right now investigators
are still working to figure out exactly
how it started joe muller is outside the
building near industrial and sahara with
what happens next
that fire tore through the roof here at
the crazy horse too you can still see
the damage and the debris left outside
from the blaze today code enforcement
officers were out here to figure out
what needs to happen next to secure the
property
the fire started early sunday morning it
left the old gentlemen's club with a
long well-known history heavily damaged
the fire took hours to get under control
the gate and the back doors to the
building were open and we saw some
people going inside monday code
enforcement came to the property to see
what will be needed to secure it las
vegas fire and rescue public information
officer timothy zamanski says the
investigation is just getting started
what we want to do is find out from the
owner who the insurance company is that
owns that property there
usually on a large lost fire like on a
building like that we want to coordinate
our investigation with possibly
investigators from the insurance company
i spoke to a representative from l.a
based westland development group who
tells me they manage the property they
say someone was heading to las vegas to
look at the building and to figure out
what to do
due to the damage they plan to tear it
down they will most likely replace it
with a new development but would not say
what that would be now fire
investigators are waiting for that
contact with the insurance company to
continue their investigation zamanski
says it could take some time before we
know what caused it reporting near the
strip joe moulder live local now